risk and benefit every medicine has it
and has been brought into
sharp focus by the rumble over
astrazeneca's covid vaccine
several countries have reported people
developing blood clots soon after having
the jab
and many have suspended their vaccine
rollout as a precaution
according to the european medicines
agency there have been
30 cases in five million vaccinated
people across the continent
but blood clots are common around one in
a thousand people a year develop one
because of medical conditions
or medication including the pill
when you vaccinate millions of people
it's inevitable that you have
rare or serious incidences
of illnesses that occur after
vaccination
and our role at the ema is to
evaluate these to make sure that any
suspected
adverse reactions are rapidly
investigated so we can figure out
is this a real side effect to the
vaccine or is it a coincidence
so what about certain types of blood
clots then well the german and norwegian
health authorities took action because
of reported
clots causing brain hemorrhages in
younger people
it's called cerebral venous sinus
thrombosis
and in germany there have been seven
cases out of
1.6 million vaccinations that's a rate
of around four and a half per million
people
that does look a little higher than
you'd expect doctors estimate the
background rate of cvst
in people under the age of 50 would be
one or two
per month per million people but those
numbers are small and they still
don't prove a causal link with a vaccine
against any possible risk
you have to weigh up the benefits and
covid kills
even in middle-aged men the mortality
rate is around
1 000 death per million infections
deaths
the vaccine largely prevents still torn
by the risk and benefit well bear this
in mind
paracetamol a drug so many of us use
regularly
well there's a one in a million chance
of liver failure even with standard
doses a very real
safety risk as for astrazeneca's jab
the european medicines regulator is
looking at the individual reports of
clots to see if there really is
a good reason to stop the roll out of a
life-saving vaccine